2023 die Zahl der geflüchteten in
Deutschland steigt und steigt Kommunen
und Länder sind am
Limit Forderungen werden laut nach
Abschreckung Abschottung
Abschiebung wo eine abschiebe Grund
vorhanden ist dann will ich dass diese
Abschiebung auch schnell wie möglich
funktioniert der Staat ringt um
Kontrolle das sind eben noch nicht
erfolgreich genug doch hinter jeder
Abschiebung steckt eine persönliche
Geschichte ich habe jetzt dre Jahre
gelebt ich habe alles gemacht aber
trotzdem sagst nein du darf nicht
manchmal habe ich schon den Eindruck
dass es um die Abschiebung um jeden
Preis
geht wer darf bleiben wer wird
abgeschoben eine Debatte voller
Emotionen zusätzlich aufgeheizt dort wo
Asylbewerber zu Straftätern
werden 15jähriger Junge aus Afghanistan
soll ein gleichaltges Mädchen erstochen
haben Gerät der Rechtsstaat bei
Abschiebungen an seine
[Musik]
Grenzen am Münchner Flughafen steht ein
Passagierflugzeug bereit an
bord6 abgesenerden sollen einer von
ihnen ist der
22jährigeibemi ich habe meine Beste
gegeben ich habe alles gemacht weil ich
wollte eigentlich nechen flassen 101
Bundespolizisten sind im Einsatz
kostenpunkt rund 360 000
[Musik]
€ jede hat vi Leute gehabt ich hab Ex le
bei
mir das fande ich mich shber interessant
warum
denn ich habe keine Leute getöet ich bin
keine kminal nur RUL abgelnt da hat mir
richtig traurig gemacht ich habe
aufgefragt warum so so
geht Hasib soll mit einer sogenannten
Sammelabschiebung zurück nach
Afghanistan kurz bevor die Taliban dort
die Macht übernehmen in Deutschland regt
sich
Protest
s
absieung
g doch der Flieger nach Kabul hebt wie
geplant ab hasassibs Geschichte ist die
Geschichte einer deutschen
Abschiebung wie ist es dazu
gekommen ein nicht enden wollender Strom
erschöpfter und verzweifelter ver es
genau sind weiß niemand hunderte Ungarn
verlassen die meisten wollen nach
Deutschland im Sommer 2015 kommen
innerhalb weniger Monate 100000
geflüchtete nach
[Applaus]
Deutschland die Kanzlerin Angela Merkel
entscheidet die Menschen ins Land zu
lassen wir haben so vieles geschafft wir
schaffen das wir schaffen das und wo uns
etwas im Wege steht muss es überwunden
werden doch nicht alle in der
Bevölkerung ziehen mit Gastfreundschaft
werde ausgenutzt Zuwanderung passiere
unkontrolliert die Behörden seien
überfordert
die meisten Menschen fliehen vor dem
Bürgerkrieg in Syrien andere kommen aus
Eritrea Irak oder
Afghanistan dort wütet in Teilen die
radikal islamistische Terrororganisation
Taliban seit Jahrzehnten das Land kommt
einfach nicht zur
Ruhe Familien werden auseinandergissen
so auch bei Hasib
assemi sein ältester Bruder wird
umgebracht Hasib und seine Familie
wollen nur noch weg wir konnten nicht
weiter leben daswegen mein Papa hat ein
Sohn verloren das hat
Angst gehabt er hat gesagt wir wollen
nicht
weiter Hasib ist 17 Jahre alt als die
Familie 2015 Afghanistan
verlässt auf der Flucht werden sie
getrennt Eltern und Geschwister bleiben
in der
türkeiib ein Bruder und ein Neffe
schaffen es bis in die
wir haben mit unserer lieben gespielt da
war nicht einfach da war daer Z D Monate
unterwegs wir waren in Griechenland dann
weiter anderes Land die kommen noch
Leute nehmen uns weiter weiter so dann
wir sind in
Deutschland die Polizei greift die drei
Männer in Deutschland auf und teilt
Ihnen einen Wohnort
[Applaus]
zu das bayerische
wigensbach
5000 Einwohner drei Fußballfelder jeden
Mittwoch Markt und ein
Gasthof wir wussen nicht wo sind wir wir
wusssen nicht wo soll wir einkaufen
gehen wenn man ein neues Land kommt ein
neue Gesetz z.B in Deutschland gibt man
darf nicht auf dem Straße rote Ampel
laufen bei uns gibt nicht das war
so interess Hasib fängt ein neues Leben
an mit Unterstützung von außen er geht
zur Schule lernt Regeln und Deutsch und
arbeitet auf dem
Wertstoffhof irgendwann nach rund 8
Monaten in Wiggensbach bekommt er eine
Einladung für seine Anhörung im
Asylverfahren
[Musik]
der wichtigste Termin im Asylverfahren
ist die Anhörung die geflüchteten
berichten den Entscheidern des bampf
warum sie geflohen sind Susanne hubach
ist eine von
1650 entscheiderinnen und Entscheidern
in
Deutschland Anhörungen sind der zentrale
Teil des Verfahrens da in der Regel ein
Beweis Notstand vorliegt die wenigsten
Menschen kommen mit umfangreichsten
Unterlagen um letztendlich ihre ihr
verfolgungsschicksal dokumentieren zu
können das heißt die geflüchteten sind
in der Beweispflicht sie müssen ihre
Verfolgung in irgendeiner Form belegen
oft geschieht dies durch die Schilderung
ihrer persönlichen Geschichte übersetzt
durch Dolmetscher ich möchte Sie bitten
mir zu schildern aus welchem Grund sie
sich entschlossen haben die Türkei zu
verlassen hat man mich der Arbeitgeber
hat mich unter anderem gezwungen Ware zu
schmuckeln ich war absolut dagegen
danach war ich seitens Arbeitgeber Tod
war ich seitens des Arbeitgebers mit
Todesdrohungen konfrontiert
Punt auf Grundlage der Erzählung und mit
Blick auf die Situation im
Herkunftsland bestimmen dann allein die
Entscheider ob jemand internationalen
Schutz bekommt also in Deutschland
bleiben darf oder nicht
es nutzt auch nichts wenn wir mit den
Antragsstellern tief mitfühlen und dann
am Ende unsere eigentliche Aufgabe
vergessen die Entscheidungen obliegen
Recht und Gesetz und das kennt drei
schutzformen der Flüchtlingsschutz
greift wenn eine Person wegen ihrer
ethnischen Herkunft Religion
Zugehörigkeit zu einer bestimmten
sozialen Gruppe oder wegen ihrer
politischen Überzeugung verfolgt
wird auch wenn den Personen die
Todesstrafe oder willkürliche Gewalt
durch einen Krieg droht kann ihnen
Schutz zugesprochen
werden nationale Abschiebungsverbote
gelten wenn der Person im Zielstaat eine
konkrete Gefahr für Leib leben oder
Freiheit droht z.B weil dort
Menschenrechte verletzt
werden von Januar bis August
2023 waren 22% der Entscheidungen eine
Ablehnung sie fielen laut Entscheidung
des bampf nicht unter diese
schutzform auch hasibs Asylantrag wird
abgelehnt ja das find ich
scheiße ja ich habe jetzt dre Jahre
gelebt ich habe die Sprache gelernt und
ich habe alles gemacht ich habe
gearbeitet aber trotzd sagst nein du
darf nicht der Antragsteller wird
aufgefordert die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland innerhalb von 30 Tagen nach
Bekanntgabe dieser Entscheidung zu
verlassen sollte der Antragsteller die
Ausreisefrist nicht einhalten wird er
nach Afghanistan
abgeschoben
Hasib soll Deutschland verlassen sein
Bruder und sein Neffe die im gleichen
Ort leben wie Hasib dürfen dagegen
bleiben ihr Asylantrag wird
angenommen die Entscheidung ist für
Hasib schwer nachzuvollziehen das ich
hab so komisch gefunden
warum wir sind gleiche family warum eine
darf schon eine muss
raus es ist immer schwer vergleichbar es
gibt immer wieder individuale Aspekte
die letztendlich voneinander abweichen
aber wie wir ein Einzelfall letztendlich
beurteilen hängt wirklich auch von den
Umständen dieses Einzelfalls
ab jeder Asylbewerber hat seine eigene
Geschichte unterschiedliche Geschichte
unterschiedliche Entscheidung
hasibs Bruder hat einen minderjährigen
Sohn Hasib ist volljährig und
alleinstehend ihm bleibt noch eine
Möglichkeit Hasib nimmt sich einen
Anwalt und klagt gegen die Entscheidung
des bmpf das macht nicht nur er 2017
reichen neun von Zeh abgelehnten
Asylbewerbern Klage ein und fast jeder
zweite gewinnt
bekommt also doch Schutz in Deutschland
die Kosten muss dann das bamppf
Übernehmen sprich die Steuerzahler
allein 2017 sind das rund 20 Millionen
Euro die Debatte über eine schnellere
Abschiebung abgelehnter Asylbewerber
wird noch vom CSU landesgruppenchef
Alexander dobrint befeuert ist nicht
akzeptabel dass eine
antiabschiebeindustrie dafür sorgt dass
die Bemühungen des Rechtsstaates
unterlaufen
werden für Anwältinnen wie Anna fröhlich
die abgelehnte Schutzsuchende vorgericht
vertritt sind solche Kommentare schwer
nachvollziehbar wir sind Rechtsanwälte
wir sind parteiisch und jeder Anwalt
auch in anderen Rechtsgebieten versucht
für seinen Mandanten das bestmögliche
Ergebnis zu erreichen und das ist der
Sinn und Zweck eines Rechtsstaates dass
jeder seine bestmögliche Vertretung
rechtliche Vertretung hat und hat nichts
mit einer
antiabschiebeindustrie zu
tun jeder Mensch hat in Deutschland das
Recht gegen die Entscheidung einer
Behörde vorzugehen auch
Asylsuchende im Fall von Hasib asemi
bestätigt das Gericht die Entscheidung
des BAMF seine Klage wird abgelehnt
Hasib ist auf beamtenende deutsch
vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig für ihn persönlich
bedeutet das zurück in ein Land das mehr
und mehr von den Taliban eingenommen
wird nachdem er vier Jahre in
Deutschland gelebt hat ich habe keinen
Afghanistan wie wie soll ich freiwillig
nach Afghanistan gehen was soll ich
machen
da rechtlich hat Hasib keine Chance
mehr bei solchen Fällen ist die
Konsequenz klar findet Joachim Hermann
Innenminister von Bayern dem Bundesland
aus dem nach NRW abgeschoben wird wenn
ein deutsches Gericht in seiner
Unabhängigkeit entschieden hat es darf
jemand nicht in Deutschland bleiben er
hat kein Aufenthaltsrecht hier dann ist
es nur einfach notwendig und richtig
dass so jemand auch unser Land wieder
verlässt es muss einfach konsequent
gehandelt werden und wir haben zu viele
Menschen in unserem Land die
offensichtlich kein Recht haben sich
hier aufzuhalten
in Deutschland leben im Juni 2023 etwa
280.000 Menschen die vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig sind etwa die Hälfte
davon sind abgelehnte Asylbewerber so
wie Hasib es war aber nur ein Bruchteil
davon rund 8000 Menschen wurden im
ersten Halbjahr 2023 tatsächlich
abgeschoben woran liegt das nur weil
Menschen ausreisepflichtig sind heißt
das nicht zwingend d sie abgeschoben
werden können etwa 90% der abgelehnten
Asylbewerber haben eine sogenannte
Duldung das heißt ihre Abschiebung wird
ausgesetzt sie gilt erstmal für maximal
6 Monate und muss dann immer wieder
verlängert werden das kann auf Dauer
nicht funktionieren entweder werden die
Leute abgeschoben oder die kriegen die
Chance in Deutschland zu bleiben kein
festen aufenthalttitel zu haben und in
Kettenduldung zu sein über Jahre kann
sehr zermürbend sein und und Menschen
depressiv machen hoffnungslos machen und
ermüden und erschöpfen weil sie immer
wieder in Situation kommen wo sie
eigentlich nicht planen können wo sie
nicht wissen wie ihr Leben weitergeht wo
sie auch immer wieder auch Angst haben
müssen wenn sie zur Behörde gehen wird
die Duldung erneut verlängert oder
nicht generell bekommen abgelehnte
Asylbewerber eine Duldung wenn sie krank
sind einer geregelten Arbeit nachgehen
oder eine Ausbildung machen der
Hauptgrund ist allerdings schlicht
fehlende Reisedokumente
häufig kassieren Schlepper passpapiere
ein oder die Dokumente gehen auf der
Flucht verloren einigen Asylbewerbern
wird auch vorgeworfen dass sie ihre
Papiere bewusst zurücklassen oder
beseitigen um eine Abschiebung zu
verhindern fakt ist abgelehnte
Asylbewerber ohne Pass sind verpflichtet
sich neue Papiere zu besorgen sonst
drohen ihnen Strafen es liegt ja auch an
den Heimatbehörden für ihre Angehörigen
Pässe auszustellen identitätsdokumente
auszustellen und wenn das die Behörde
nicht macht aus welchen Gründen auch
immer habe ich das nicht zu verantworten
und es ärgert mich auch immer wieder
dass das so als so einfach dargestellt
wird und die Schuld in die Hände der
ausreisepflichtigen gelegt wird dass sie
sich da nicht um Papiere kümmern ja das
ist nämlich schwierig es ist komplex und
ich habe schon oft passbeschaffungen
begleitet und ähm ich habe Fälle gehabt
in denen ich z D vi Jahre mich selber
mit dem anten zusammen um den Pass
bemüht
habe jeder asylfall ist ein Einzelfall
die bürokratischen Abläufe sind oft
komplex nicht immer durchsichtig und
dauern sehr lange bis alle Fakten
geklärt sind können abgelehnte
Asylbewerber nicht abgeschoben
werden gleichzeitig kommen jeden Tag
weitere geflüchtete nach Deutschland von
Januar bis September 2023 haben über
eine viertel Million Menschen einen
Asylantrag gestellt das sind bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt schon mehr als im
gesamten Jahr
2022 vor allem weil sich die Lage in
Syrien und Afghanistan massiv
verschlechtert hat fliehen wieder mehr
Menschen hinzu kommen die vielen
geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine deutschland steuert wieder auf
eine migrationskrise zu die Last tragen
Länder und Kommunen sie stoßen an ihre
Grenzen und schlagen
Alarm die Stimmung im Land meine Damen
und Herren m die droh zu kippen die
Frage der Rückführung ist für die
Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung für die
Aufnahme von Schutzsuchenden von großer
Bedeutung um die Kommunen wirklich
langfristig zu entlasten brauchen wir
jetzt die im Koalitionsvertrag
verankerten migrations und
Rückführungsabkommen die sowohl
gesteuerte Migration ermöglichen als
auch Rückführung
erleichtern dass sich sogar die Grünen
für leichteres abschieben aussprechen
zeigt die Dringlichkeit der Situation
und auch Olaf Scholz ein
sozialdemokratischer Kanzler schlägt im
Herbst 2023 einen anderen Ton
an laut ZDF Politbarometer sind 59% der
Deutschen im August
2023 für schärfere
abschieberegelungen an vielen Stellen
erleben die Menschen viel Unsicherheit
Unsicherheit in ihren Existenzen aber
auch Unsicherheit in dem was eine Grenze
ist die haben migrations nicht nur
Anlässe sondern auch Möglichkeiten
Menschen kommen es ist eben egal wie
versucht wird das irgendwie
einzumauern viele Menschen sind
verunsichert sie wünschen sich von der
Politik mehr Kontrolle Orientierung und
Sicherheit die Abschiebung ist ein
Instrument des Staates souveräen Staates
um eben auch Handlungsfähigkeit zu
zeigen um zu zeigen wir haben die
Migrationskontrolle
haben wir sozusagen in der Hand wir
wissen wir können es
Regeln aber die Frage ist kann
Deutschland das
[Musik]
Regeln nur eine von drei geplanten
Abschiebungen konnte im Jahr 2022
tatsächlich durchgeführt werden das
heißt insgesamt über 23 000
Abschiebungen konnten nicht durchgeführt
werden davon wurden über 15000 vorab
storiert weitere 7000 konnten
kurzfristig nicht stattfinden weil die
ausreisepflichtigen nicht zum Flughafen
gebracht werden konnten die genauen
Gründe dafür werden statistisch nicht
erfasst der Druck von Bevölkerung und
Opposition auf die ampelregierung
wächst das sieht auch der FDP
migrationspolitiker Stefan
Tom zumindest bei denen die nicht einmal
eine Duldung haben muss die Abschiebung
dann schon durchgeführt werden und das
sind eben noch nicht erfolgreich genug
der Unmut über die Migrationspolitik der
der Ampel ist groß viele Menschen
wünschen konsequentes durchgreifen so
wie es die AFD
verspricht wir werden abschieben
abschieben abschieben das verspreche ich
euch eine einfache abschieberetorik die
ein Nerv
trifft sowohl in Bayern als auch in
Hessen fährt die AFD bei den
Landtagswahlen im Oktober 2023
rekgebnisse
ein dennoch ganz so einfach ist es für
ein nicht Menschen
abzuschiebenib z.B wurde vor seiner
drohenden Abschiebung
gewarnt ich habe schon gewusst mein Name
ist im abschieben LTE deswegen ich würde
nicht zu mir nach Hause gehe ich bin
immer verstck mit Kumpel mit Freunde
immer mich
Verst als die Polizei hasassib am 6
November 2019 abholen will ist er
bewusst nicht da der Staat kann die
Abschiebung nicht
durchführen Hasib will nicht zurück nach
Afghanistan auch wenn der Traum von
einer Ausbildung und einer neuen Heimat
in Deutschland weit wegscheeint um einem
erneuten abschiebungsversuch zu entgehen
flieht er im Winter 2019 nach Frankreich
ich wusste nicht was soll ich machen
aber ich habe versuchen vielleicht ich
krieg eine Zukunft in
Frankreich vielleicht Frank kann
unselfen Hasib beantragt auch in
Frankreich Asyl
über Monate lebt er auf der
[Musik]
Straße erst nach über einem Jahr ist
klar hasibs Asylantrag wird in
Frankreich nicht bearbeitet der Grund
die Zuständigkeit liegt in
Deutschland in der EU Reg die
duinverordnung stat für die Durchführung
eines Asylverfahrens zuständig ist und
zwar der in dem die geflüchteten als
erstes registriert
wurden Hasib wird schließlich verhaftet
und im Januar 2021 zurück nach
Deutschland
gebracht dort kommt er ins
rheinlandpelsische Ingelheim in
[Musik]
Abschiebungshaft das Gefängnis für
ausreisepflichtige Ingelheim weder hier
noch in einer anderen
abschiebungshaftanstalt in Deutschland
gibt es eine Dreherlaubnis für diesen
Film Hasib beschreibt wie er dort
untergebracht wurde dies Zimmer war ein
Toilette und ein bet fertig wie ein
kminal warum ich habe wie viel Leute
getutet das kein Mensch recht wir dürf
im Tag halbe Stunde raus wenn ich in
mein Zimmer
die Tür gesperrt was das bedeutet ich
vergesse dieser Zeit neemals in mein
Leben der Vorwurf gegen ihn er ist
untergetaucht um seiner Abschiebung zu
entgehen dann muss man aufgrund der
Erfahrung beim ersten mal sagen den
können wir jetzt nicht mehr mög
auszubüchsen sondern so jemand muss dann
eben in Abschiebungshaft in aber aller
Regel nur ganz wenige Tage dauert
genommen
werden im Durchschnitt sind
ausreisepflichtige zwischen zwei bis
vier Wochen in Haft laut Gesetz könnten
sie sogar bis zu 18 Monate eingesperrt
werden das ist natürlich ein Hammer und
das sind alles keine Straftäter was man
denen vorwirft das ist dass sie das Land
nicht verlassen haben obwohl sie es
müssten und diese Menschen über Monate
oder anderthalb Jahre maximal einsperren
zu
können das ist aus meiner Sicht völlig
unverhältnismäßig seit 2017 werden
deutschlandweit
abschiebungshafteinrichtungen aus oder
neu
gebaut die Anzahl der
abschiebungshaftplätze hat sich damit
auf insgesamt 800 verdoppelt und warum
das ganze es gab eine Kaskade an
Verschärfung seit
2015 in jeder Hinsicht und das ganze
firmierte so ein bisschen weg von der
Willkommenskultur hin zur
abschiedskultur man hat neue Haftgründe
gefunden ganz neue haftformen erfunden
z.B etwas das heißt Ausreise Gewahrsam
was so behütend klingt das ist aber ganz
normale Inhaftierung mit dem Unterschied
dass man dafür noch nicht mal
Fluchtgefahr in sich tragen muss als
betroffen Peter Fahlbusch vertritt seit
über 20 Jahren fast ausschließlich
Menschen die in Abschiebungshaft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sitzen das allermeiste an Fehlern
passiert da wo es nicht kompliziert es
geht los mit Festnahmen geplante
Festnahmen ohne richterliche
Entscheidung das ist einfach
verfassungswidrig dann sind die Leute im
Gefängnis und werden dort vergessen
schlicht vergessen ja da haben sie den
Supergau natürlich Menschen einzusperren
die das Land gar nicht verlassen müssen
und dann haben sie natürlich die ganz
schlimmen Fälle haftunfähige Leute
kranke alte
suizidgefährdete die da nicht hingehören
und trotzdem untergebracht
werden was lautch helfen könnte wenn
ausreisepflichtige von Tag 1 ihrer
Festnahme einen pflichtanwalt bekämen
der Justizminister sagt das brauche es
nicht weil es ja nicht so schlecht läuft
wie wir behaupten woher das weiß weiß
kein Mensch Zahlen dazu hat er
jedenfalls
[Musik]
nicht weder Bund noch Länder
dokumentieren wie viele
ausreisepflichtige zu Unrecht in
Abschiebungshaft sitzen eine Blackbox
peter fahbusch hat zahlen weil er über
seine Fälle eine genaue Statistik
führt von den
2458 Menschen die er seit 2001 in
abschiebungshaftverfahren vertreten hat
wurden
1283 also etwa die Hälfte zu Unrecht
inhaftiert im Durchschnitt saßen sie
fast vier Wochen lang im
Gefängnis dabei ist Abschiebungshaft
teuer 400 bis 600 € kostet ein Häftling
pro Tag meist zahlen das am Ende die
Steuerzahler warum hält die Politik an
dieser Praxis der Abschiebungshaft fest
Abschiebehaft ist die ultima ratio
nachdem Menschen ihre
Aufforderung das Land zu verlassen nicht
nachgekommen sind und insofern führt da
kein Weg drum
herum
Abschiebungshaft also als ein wichtiges
Mittel um die Ausreisepflicht konsequent
durchzusetzen
härter durchgreifen so der Wille fast
aller Parteien vor allem straffällig
gewordene Asylbewerber sollen konsequent
abgeschoben
[Musik]
werden es geschieht immer wieder
einzelne Straftaten von Zuwanderern
schockieren die
Bevölkerung am 5 dezember 2022 greift
ein Asylbewerber aus Eritrea in
Kirchberg bei Ulm zwei Mädchen mit einem
Messer an eine erliegt ihren
Verletzungen nur wenige Wochen später
attackiert ein statenloser in einem
Regionalzug in Schleswig-Holstein
mehrere Menschen für zwei Jugendliche
erst 17 und 19 Jahre alt kommt jede
Hilfe zu spät der Täter hätte eigentlich
abgeschoben werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sollen
warum gelingt es nicht solche Fälle zu
verhindern
extremismusexperte und Psychologe Ahmad
Mansur hat dazu eine klare
Position es gibt Menschen die dieses
Land verachten es gibt Menschen die
schwere Straftaten begangen haben und
die muss auch der Weg aus der
Gesellschaft gezeigt werden ich glaube
nicht dass wir eine Willkommenskultur
installieren knen ohne Abschiebung es
erwartet auch ganz offens
die große Mehrheit der Menschen in
unserem Land dass solche Straftäter
unser Land wieder
verlassen die Debatte bekommt eine neue
Dimension als am 7 Oktober
2023 die proalästinensische
Terrororganisation Hamas Israel angreift
und hunderte Menschen entführt und
tötet Hamas Sympathisanten feiern auch
auf deutschen
Straßen
wie sollen wie können wir damit
umgehen diejenigen die wir entweder
nicht haben wollen weil sie sich nicht
anpassen wollen weil sie Verbrecher sind
weil sie den Tod von Juden in Israel in
Deutschland feiern die müssen dann eben
aber auch ab rückgeführt werden so das
geht diejenigen die den Rechtsstaat
nicht achten sollen das Land verlassen
das klingt einfacher als es in der
Praxis oft
ist in der Hansestadt ist 2016 die
gemeinsame Ermittlungsgruppe zur
Rückführung ausländischer Straftäter
kurz Geras gegründet worden ihr Ziel
straffällig gewordene Migranten
schneller
abschieben Kriminalhauptkommissar Martin
Hinzer und seine Kollegen arbeiten hier
sehr eng mit der Ausländerbehörde
zusammen nicht alle wollen offen gefilmt
werden wir haben potenziell neuen gerers
Fall genau im Zuge der täglichen
lagerauswertung bin ich auf Herrn Z
gestoßen der in den letzten sech Monaten
bereits 22 Straftaten in Hamburg
begangen hat haben wir ein Wohnort
Adresse irgendwas relevantes zu ihm gar
nichts das beginnt eben genau damit
sichere Identifizierung der Person
herbeizuführen es geht dann darum
erkennnisse abzufragen welche
erkennnisse liegen möglich Weise in
anderen europäischen Staaten bezüglich
der Person vor wo ist die Person
möglicherweise durch andere Straftaten
bereits aufgetaucht was gibt's
möglicherweise aus Anhörung für Hinweise
mit denen man dann wiederum arbeiten
kann ist weder die Identität noch das
Herkunftsland bekannt ist eine
Abschiebung aussichtslos auch wenn es
sich um Straftäter handelt Geras
Aufnahme bedeutet nicht dass jeder Fall
tatsächlich in einer Rückführung endet
denn manchmal sind da Hemmnisse die eine
Rückführung einfach nicht ermöglichen in
den 7 Jahren seit Bestehen hat die
Ermittlungsgruppe insgesamt 470 Fälle
auf dem Tisch bis September 2023 kann
sie 209 Straftäter zurückführen über ein
Drittel der Fälle wird immer noch
bearbeitet eines der großen Probleme
sind die Herkunftsländer es kommt immer
wieder vor dass diese ihre Staatsbürger
einfach nicht zurücknehmen
wenn die Probleme in dem Herkunftsland
liegen da kann natürlich nur die
Bundesregierung aktiv werden weil die
Länder sind nicht dafür zuständig
auswtige Beziehungen zu Nigeria oder
Kamerun oder welchem Land auch immer in
Afrika zu
pflegen die Bundesregierung möchte
deshalb vermehrt Abkommen mit den
Herkunftsstaaten schließen ein
migrationsabkommen funktioniert nur wenn
es ein Geben und Nehmen ist wenn für das
das Zielland der der Abschiebung auch in
gewisser vor Vorteil daran liegt zu
kooperieren wiaerleichterung nach
Deutschland sind eine anreizmöglichkeit
um mit der anderen Regierung zu
vereinbaren wir verschaffen euren
Staatsbürgern leichtere
visamöglichkeiten aber müss im Gegenzug
auch Straftäter und Gefährder und
abgelehnt dasserber
zurücknehmen solche Abkommen können ein
Lösungsansatz für die Zukunft sein aber
keine Lösung für alles denn laut der
Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention kann nicht
in Länder abgeschoben werden in denen
eine Gefahr für Leib und Leben
droht man kann ja Menschen nicht mitten
in eine kriegregionen dann
zurückschicken aber das sind massive
Straftaten dabei sind diese Leute sitzen
entweder im Gefängnis oder gehen aus dem
Gefängnis raus und haben keine
Infrastruktur um überhaupt für
Resozialisation zu sorgen oder
anzukommen das heißt wir entlassen sie
in der Kriminalität wieder das kann
natürlich nicht die Lösung sein
die abschiebungsdebatte ausschließlich
auf Straftäter oder Sympathisanten von
Terrororganisationen zu fokussieren
verfälsche das Bild warnt Psychologin
chinur Kader es führt natürlich auch zu
einer anderen Wahrnehmung von
geflüchteten also für die Gesellschaft
ah das ist eine Gruppe die sind
bedrohlich und deswegen ist es auch
legitimer und sie abzuschieben also es
es erleichtert oder macht diese Schwelle
leichter auch die moralische Schwelle
leich
zu sagen sie gehören eigentlich nicht
hierhin das ist ja quasi ein Akt der
Selbstverteidigung wenn wir die
abgelehnten Asylbewerber
abschieben fakt ist die meisten
geflüchteten die tatsächlich abgeschoben
werden haben keine schweren Straftaten
begangen in der Vergangenheit sind oft
die falschen abgeschoben worden weil es
manmal leichter war eine Familie
abzuschieben der man leichter habhaft
werden konnte als eines Straftäters der
sich irgendwo steckt und und
untergetaucht
[Musik]
ist wenn Integration in Deutschland
geglückt ist warum dann noch
[Musik]
abschieben bei Abschiebungen von
Familien mit kleinen Kindern ist für
mich so eine Grenze erreicht wo ich sage
soweit muss man unsere rechtsstaatlichen
Grundsätze nicht ausreizen und man muss
nicht Grenzen überschreiten nur der
Abschiebung Willen das sind so Fälle die
mich im Bezug auf Abschiebung wirklich
erschüttern und ähm erschrecken wie weit
wir
m hier gehen um Personen abzuschieben es
gibt halt dieses Dilemma des Staates das
Vollzug ist die Aufgabe und dann gibt's
die menschenrechtliche Seite und die
Frage ist immer sozusagen die
Verhältnismäßigkeit und die
Verhältnismäßigkeit ist nicht gegeben
wenn Menschen oder Kinder die hier
geboren sind nach 10 15 Jahren in ein
Land Heimatland zurückkehren müssen dass
sie gar nicht nicht kennen wenn Familien
getrennt werden wenn psychisch
vulnerable traumatisierte Menschen an
Ort der Verfolgung zurück müssen all das
ist nicht verhältnismäßig und zugleich
müssen wir bedenken das ist geltendes
Recht und zugleich ist es geltendes
Unrecht also wir haben da
beides was ist rechtmäßig und wo beginnt
Unrecht bei Abschiebungen ist der Grad
schmal die Grenzen
verschwimmen
9 Februar
2021 an der Zellentür der
abschieberhaftanstalt Ingelheim klopft
es und komm ungefäh acht Polizei in mein
Zimmer rein hat gesagt mach deine Sache
packen leider
jetzt am Münchner Flughafen steht ein
Passagierflugzeug bereit an Bord werden
26 ausreisepflichtige Afghanen gebracht
gegen ihren Willen
unter ihn Hasib an Händen und Füßen
gefesselt Zielflughafen Kabul ich habe
einen Mann gesehen die war auf dem Bude
und Poli im Schlag die will einfach
nicht gehen die Poli seine m und ich
glaube Notarzt gekommen da war hat mir
richtig traurig gemacht
richtig wir konnte n
machen seine erählung abgelaufen ist
lassen sich nicht überprüfen eine
Blackbox denn am münchenner Flughafen
gibt es bis heute keine unabhängige
abschiebungsbeobachtung jeder darf nicht
bewegen nur manche beleidig manch weint
aber man kann nichts
machen da war ich schwierig seit echt
jetzt für Hasib beginnen zwei sehr harte
Jahre doch er gibt nicht
auf September
2023 Hasib ist wieder da im bayerischen
Allgäu die Seite soll ich machen das ja
er muss noch unimlich viel lernen mit
der Sprache hab das noch ein bisschen
aber mir kommen gut klar er hat Spaß an
der Arbeit er will
arbeiten optimal also besser geht
nicht zwei Jahre nach seiner Abschiebung
kann hasassib im März 2023 über ein
ausbildungsvisum wieder zurück nach
Deutschland kommen jetzt lernt er hier
den Beruf des
trockenbauers solange ist sein
Bleiberecht sicher
ja in Deutchland muss man ein Ausbildung
machen und das
Zukunft später man Verdi auch ganz
[Musik]
guturs Unterstützerin und Unterstützer
hatte Josefine Steiger ist eine
[Applaus]
[Musik]
davon sie setzt sich über zwei Jahre
lang für ihn ein und hilft ihm bis
heute sie hat alles wie ein Mama
gemacht ganz ehrlich sie hat mir zwei
Jahre
unglaublich schwierige seit hat mir
immer gesagt K junge und sagst immer
wenn ein T Zug geheht die komm eine auf
das ist passiert jetzt oder Frau
Steiger ja Hasib habe ich insbesondere
geholfen weil ich die Art seiner
Abschiebung für einfach unmenschlich
empfunden habe vor allem die lange Zeit
die ein Abschiebehaft war er hatte
Freunde hier ja hat Fußball gespielt
wollte sein Schulabschluss machen und
dann gibt man ihm die Chance
nicht
Steiger bleibt mit dem damals
23-Jährigen in Kontakt und beschafft ihm
in seiner Abwesenheit ein
Ausbildungsplatz und eine
Wohnung alleine schafft es niemand ganz
einfach deshalb weil der finanzielle
Aufwand sehr groß ist aber auch der
bürokratische
Aufwand denn um zurück nach Deutschland
zu kommen muss Hasib die Kosten seiner
abschiebungshft und der Abschiebung
selbst bezahlen insgesamt 23000 € diese
Bedingung stellt das deutsche
aufenthalsgesetz das hat mir wirklich
den Boden und den Füßen weggezogen wo
ich gehört habe was seine
abschiebekosten sind und dann war der
nächste Schritt ja wo kriege ich jetzt
dieses Geld
her Steiger ist gut vernetzt Freunde und
Bekannte von ihr unterstützenib
finanziell und auch der Flüchtlingsrat
übernimmt einen Teil der Kosten hasibs
legaler Wiedereinreise steht nichts mehr
im
Wege in Deutschland wird hasibs
Arbeitskraft gebraucht denn
Auszubildende vor allem in
Handwerksbetrieben werden händeringend
gesucht 2023 finden bundesweit fast die
Hälfte aller Unternehmen keine
Azubis und trotzdem sind wir so
bescheuert
und schieben Menschen ab die hier eine
Ausbildung in mangelberufen machen
könnten also ich krieg da jedes Mal da
kriege ich Herzrasen bei sowas da sehe
ich schon Versagen unserer
Ausländerbehörden dass sie sich da die
falschen Fälle rauspicken die
abgeschoben werden sollen wenn wir
merken wie viel wir investieren um
überhaupt Fachkräfte für Deutschland zu
gewinnen und dann haben wir diese
Menschen hier sie haben die Sprache
gelernt was nicht so einfach ist sie
sind ang
sie investieren ihre Zeit seit Jahren
und dann kommt jemand und sagt ja du
kamst aus dem falschen Land bei dir ist
gerade kein Krieg mehr deshalb bitte
tschüss das ist auch
[Musik]
unmenschlich weil ihr Asylantrag
abgelehnt wurde sollen sie Deutschland
verlassen dabei könnten gut integrierte
abgelehnte Asylbewerber sowie hasassib
eine Bereicherung für den Arbeitsmarkt
sein Anfang 2023 beschließ die
Bundesregierung das sogenannte
chancenaufenthaltsgesetz mit ihm soll
der ersehnte Spurwechsel möglich
werden die Idee wer 5 Jahre oder länger
hier in Deutschland lebt kann unter
bestimmten Bedingungen eine
aufenthilserlaubnis auf Probe bekommen
die Meinungen dazu sind
gespalten für mich ist das
chancenaufenhaltsgesetz Teil auch
ungerecht weil jemand der VI Jahre in
Deutschland
ist JRE sein Bestes gegeben hat der
kommt nicht in in den Genuss andere
haben
Glück sind 5 Jahre hier und haben
vielleicht gar nicht so viel
Eigeninitiative und Leistung
gebracht wir sind der Meinung dass vor
allen Dingen in der Zukunft viele
Personen den Anreiz erhalten nur auf
Biegen und Brechen irgendwo Ihren
Aufenthalt in Deutschland so lang zu
verlängern bis sie dann ein Anspruch
darauf haben auch
hier zu bleiben das sind aus meiner
Sicht die falschen
Signale die Debatte bleibt Verfahren wie
sollen wir mit Asylsuchenden umgehen s
dass es gerecht menschlich und
kontrollierbar ist wer darf bleiben und
wo muss der Rechtsstaat klare Kante
zeigen ganz ohne Abschiebungen wird es
nicht gehen weil nur auf diese Art und
Weise der Staat seine Entscheidungen
auch durchsetzen kann wenn man sich nach
dem Gesetz orientiert dann ist das
natürlich so der Mensch hat kein
aufenhaltsrecht und geht nicht
freiwillig raus und dann schieben wir
ihn ab das ist dann richtig ob das
gerecht ist weiß ich
nicht Fakt ist so wie es jetzt läuft
sind die Verfahren kompliziert und nicht
immer nachvollziehbar eine
Aneinanderreihung undurchsichtiger
Blackboxen letztlich Gerät der
rechtsstat nicht nur an seine Grenzen
sondern an in vielen Fällen wenn ich
eben auf Kinder schaue wenn ich auf
psychisch Kranke schaue auf viele andere
Konstellationen überschreitet diese
Abschiebepraxis auch häufig unsere
rechtsstaatlichen
Grenzen an anderer Stelle sind dem
Rechtsstaat die Hände gebunden bei
Straftätern die zügig abgeschoben werden
sollen aber oft nicht abgeschoben werden
können deutschland braucht Zuwanderung
die geregelt ist darin kann auch eine
Chance liegen wenn wir Wunschkonzert
hätten hab
dann wünsche ich mir dass
Integrationsleistungen belohnt werden
ich werde nie kapieren warum wir
Menschen Jahre hier zum nichtsun
verdammen und es ist so warum lassen wir
sie denn nicht
arbeiten dass Integration über den
Arbeitsmarkt funktionieren kann zeigt
hasassibs
Geschichte ich kann jetzt einfach ruhig
Leben Gott sei Dank ich bin wieder in
Deutschland da war me meine
Wunsch ich wünsche ich darf nach der
Ausbildung in Deutschland leben ich darf
Arbeiten geh wie die anderes
Leute Hasib hat eine neue Chance
bekommen aber erst nachdem er
abgeschoben wurde er hatte schlicht
Glück das System der Abschiebung in
Deutschland bleibt ein
streittha ein System voller Unklarheiten
und
Problemen
[Musik]